going to really
you know basically what keeps you going
what keeps me going well you know you
know because this is a lonely thing and
you know it's tough it's very lonely I
really admire what you guys do as far as
the rejection part of it I mean that is
just something got to get over from the
get-go I mean it's going to happen
you're going to get rejected and if you
can't handle that find something else to
do that's the bottom line if you can't
handle the rejection you need to get out
of the business because the only people
that make it have been rejected millions
of times I mean you got to fall on your
face you know to get back up and really
get somewhere so I mean as far as
rejection goes I just I figured so many
aspects of why they didn't pick me that
I can't even Rack my brains I'm crazy
enough in my head I can't even rack my
brains to try to figure out why they
didn't choose me it could be you know
I'm not old enough I'm too young I'm too
old you know my my moustache wasn't
shaved right I look like the
ex-boyfriend to the casting director I
who knows you have no that little
there's so many fun